britain's economic recovery is being
held back by labor shortages the latest
to highlight than the big business group
the cbi which reports gaps from farmers
fields to shop and factory floors they
say shortages of butchers meat
processors and fruit pickers have hit
farming and food production in
hospitality a lack of front of house and
laundry and housekeeping workers has
seen restaurants and hotels limit
bookings wagamama the latest high street
brand to admit to problems theirs with
hiring chefs skilled trades are in short
supply too welders forklift truck
drivers and electrical engineers are all
in demand and it's all compounded by the
shortage of hgv drivers around 48 000
have left the road in the last two years
alone and the data bears out the
anecdotal evidence this chart shows how
growth in the construction industry has
stalled this end is the last five months
it's fallen as a consequence of
shortages of materials parts and yes
labor and there are record vacancies
across the economy too
953 000 in the three months to july now
these shortages are the product of the
pandemic and brexit and business wants
the home office to extend the list of
jobs for which low-skilled foreigners
including eu nationals can get visas
currently the shortage occupation list
as it's known only covers skilled roles
like doctors and nurses i.t analysts and
designers even dancers an orchestral
musicians but the government has said no
and he wants businesses to train and
hire british instead and they say the
end of rishi sunak's furlough scheme
still currently paying the wages of
between 1.6 and 2 million workers may
help cbi disagrees the firms that that
have still got people on furlough
they've been paying for those so they
must be doing so in the belief that
they're going to need those workers uh
pretty soon otherwise they wouldn't have
held on to them and of course they're
going to be some dislocation the people
on that furlough scheme right now won't
necessarily have the skills to slot
straight into these vacancies that are
available right now where the shortages
are so we don't think the furlough
scheme is going to be a panacea
now in theory this could be good news
for uk employees who might expect
greater opportunities and higher wages
but the problem may not be a shortage of
workers but of those willing to do the
low skilled low paid often insecure
roles the british economy currently
demands